>> ♪ ♪
>> I THINK IT'S TERRIBLE.
IF YOU WANT TO KNOW THE TRUTH.
IT'S A DISGRACE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THAT AND SEE
THAT AND SO MANY OTHER THINGS,
WHAT IS GOING ON, A LOT OF
PEOPLE SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF
THEMSELVES AND MUCH WORSE THAN
THAT.
>> THEY CHERRY PICKED
INFORMATION FROM THE FISA
HE PROVIDED TO US ABOUT THE
GENESIS OF THE INVESTIGATION
WHICH DID NOT INVOLVE THE
DOSSIER.
>> THE ONLY AREA THAT I AM
FAMILIAR WITH THAT WE LEFT OUT
WOULD BE THE HISTORY OF CARTER
PAGE.
I EXPLAINED WHY WE LEFT THIS OUT
TO THE DIRECTOR OF THE FBI.
THE DIRECTOR OF THE FBI IS L
THE DIRECTOR OF THE FBI IS LWE
THE DIRECTOR OF THE FBI IS LWELL
AWARE OF MY CONCERNS ABOUT
MR. PAGE.
>> Bret: TOP SENATE AND HOUSE
DEMOCRATS SHOULD A LETTER TO THE
LET'S BRING IN THE PANEL.
BYRON YORK, SUSAN PAGE, AND MATT
SCHLAPP.
>> WELL, THE FIRST THING ON THE
MEMO ITSELF, THERE ARE TWO BIG
POINTS.
ONE IS SAID THE MEMO WAS AN
ESSENTIAL PART OF THIS EFFORT TO
GET A WIRETAP WARRANT ON CARTER
PAGE.
TWO IT SAID ANDREW McCABE NUMBER
2 AT THE FBI SAID WITHOUT THE
DOSSIER THERE WOULD NOT HAVE
BEEN A WARRANT.
>> ONE CLARIFICATION.
IT'S NOT A QUOTE IN THAT PART.
I ASKED NUNES ABOUT THAT.
HE SAID THERE WAS A PROCESS TO
PUT OUT THE TRANSCRIPT OF
McCABE.
THEY WOULD HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THAT TO GET THE TRANSCRIPT PUT
OUT.
BUT HE SAID IT WAS AN INTEGRAL
PART AND THE FBI LED WITH THE
DOSSIER IN THE FISA
APPLICATIONS>> THERE IS ALSO THE
POSSIBILITY THAT SOMEBODY ELSE
THERE WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN AN
APPLICATION.
THOSE ARE TWO REALLY, REALLY BIG
THINGS.
ON THE OTHER HAND, THEN YOU LOOK
THEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT THE FBI,
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND
THIS WOULD BE AN ASSAULT ON THE
YOU ASK:
DOES IT DO THAT?
I THINK THE ANSWER IS NO.
>> I AGREE THE QUESTION ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT THEY COULD HAVE
GOTTEN THE FISA WARRANT WITHOUT
THE DOSSIER, THAT'S AN IMPORTANT
POINT AND UNDERDISPUTE BETWEEN
THE TWO PARTIES.
I HOPE WE KNOW WHAT HE SAID AND
THE TRUTH ON.
THAT THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
ABOUT THIS REPORT OUT TODAY IS
-- PURPOSES.
FOR INSTANCE THE PRESIDENT'S
TWEET AND THE COMMENTS YOU JUST
AIRED INDICATE HE WOULD LIKE TO
FIRE PEOPLE AS A RESULT OF THIS.
THAT COULD BE EXTREMELY
CONSEQUENCIAL.
>> MATT, THE TALK ON BOTH SIDES,
SOME CONGRESSMEN ARE PIPING THIS
UP AS THE MOMENT OF THE BIGGEST
THINGS.
OTHERS WERE TOO.
ON THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE THEY WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT SOURCES AND
METHODS AND WHAT WOULD THIS DO
TO THE INSTITUTION.
WHERE IS THE TRUTH HERE?
>> BRET, IS IT GOING TO DESTROY
OUR NATIONAL SECURITY?
AND IT'S CALLED A NOTHING BURGER
AND IT'S NOT IMPORTANT?
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS WHO HAVE
BEEN CRITICAL OF DEVIN NUNES
NEED TO PICK A LANE.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT -- YOU
BACK OF THOSE FOLKS WHO USED THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO GO AFTER A
POLITICAL OPPONENT.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO TAKE A BREATH.
A LOT OF CONSERVATIVES DON'T
LIKE FISA AND DON'T LIKE THE
GOVERNMENT SPYING ON AMERICANS.
ARE WE OKAY WITH ONE
ADMINISTRATION USING THESE
POWERS TO GO AFTER THEIR
POLITICAL OPPONENT?
I THINK THAT IS VERY SCARY.
>> Bret: THERE WERE 2 TRUMP
APPOINTED DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERALS WHO CONTINUED THE FISA
SURVEILLANCE?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> Bret: WHAT DOES THAT TELL
YOU?
>> THEY MIGHT HAVE JOB SECURITY
ISSUES NUMBER 1.
-- DOUBT.
IF YOU READ THE FISA MEMO THIS
WAS DONE TO ADVANCE THE
DEMOCRATS AND HILLARY CLINTON,
WHY WOULD THEY WANT TO CONTINUE
IT?
EVEN THE RUSSIAN SAID CARTER
PAGE WAS AN IDJOT AND DIDN'T
WANT TO USE HIM AS A
WANT TO USE HIM AS A SPY.
EKE
EK
>> Bret: AND STEELE SAID HE WAS
DESPERATE THAT DONALD TRUMP NOT
GET ELECTED AND WAS PASSIONATE
ABOUT HIM NOT BEING PRESIDENT.
>> I THINK THAT PART IS LESS
IMPORTANT THAN THE FACT THAT THE
DOSSIER WAS A RESEARCH PRODUCT
FUNDED BY THE DEMOCRATS.
I DO THINK MAYBE ONE OF THE MOST
BENEFICIAL EFFECTS RIGHT NOW IS
THE RELEASE OF THIS MEMO CREATED
MOMENTUM FOR THE RELEASE OF MORE
STUFF.
WE WANT TO SEE THE McCABE
INTERVIEW?
WHAT IS REALLY IN THE FISA
APPLICATION?
WE WANT TO SEE THAT TOO.
WHAT IS IN THE DEMOCRAT'S
LETTER?
WE NEED TO SEE MORE RATHER THAN
LESS.
>> Bret: SUSAN, OVERLOOKED IN
THE END OF THE INTERVIEW, NUNES
SAID MORE IS COMING.
FISA.
THERE IS BE AN OFFICIAL CALL FOR
ANOTHER SPECIAL COUNSEL.
>> WHAT IS INTERESTING IS NOT
THE PARTISAN DIVIDE.
AND THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND
THE WHITE HOUSE ON THE OTHER